>> Greg: COLLEGE CAMPUSES, ARE
SUCH PLACES GETTING ANY SAFER?
NOT FROM THE WALKING BRAIN DEAD
FOR A NEW STUDY SHOWS THAT BADLY
EDUCATED FAR LEFT ACTIVIST
CONTINUES TO LABEL WORDS AND
IDEAS SILENCED AS EVIL, TURNING
TO THE EAST GERMAN POLICE.
AND HE SAID HE FOUND A QUARTER
OF STUDENTS BELIEVES YOU CAN
SILENCED VIEWS THAT THEY DON’T
LIKE, AND IT’S OKAY TO OBSTRUCT
SPEAKERS TO DO SO.
SIX TIMES AS MANY LIBERALS FELT
THAT WAY AS NONLIBS.
ALL CONSERVATIVE SAID THEY BE
FRIENDS WITH A LIBERAL, A LARGE
MINORITY OF LIBS DID NOT
RECIPROCATE.
THIS IS WHERE YOU SEND YOUR KIDS
KIDS, NOT TO BE EDUCATED BUT TO
BE INDEBTED TO, NO LONGER TO
ENGAGE BUT TO PUNISH EACH OTHER.
IT’S A PLACE WHERE IT’S
GATEKEEPERS REALIZE THE ONLY WAY
TO PRESERVE THEIR BAD IDEAS IS
TO AND LIST ZOMBIE STUDENTS
AGAINST THE REBELLIOUS PEARS
LIKE IN A PRISON CAMP.
DOESN’T HELP HELP SHAPE YOUNG
MINDS?
THEY COULD BE SHAPED INTO WHAT,
ONE WONDERS?
>> DEATH TO FASCISTS!
>> WHAT THE [BLEEP]!
YOU ARE DISGUSTING!
>> Greg: ARE THOSE HEALTHY
MINDS, ARE THEY PEOPLE YOU CAN
WORK WITH UPON GRADUATION?
NO!
YOU DON’T WANT TO BE AROUND THAT
THAT.
COMMUNITY, EMPATHY,
NONCONFORMITY, FREE THOUGHT ARE
OPPRESSIVE.
ONCE PARENTS AND THEIR KIDS TO
BE EDUCATED, NOW THEY ARE
SENDING THEM TO BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED!
IT’S A CUCKOO’S NEST, AND
LUNATICS ARE COMING FOR YOU.
ALL RIGHT, GERALDO.
YOU WERE A YOUNG DUDE IN THE
’60s, IS THIS DIFFERENT?
WERE THERE MORE INTELLIGENCE?
>> Geraldo: IT WAS PRETTY
ROUGH IN THE ’60s AND PRETTY
INTOLERANT IN THE LEFT.
I THINK IT STICKS OUT MORE
BECAUSE WE’VE HAD A COUPLE OF
DECADES OF GENTILITY.
WE ARE SHOCKED, BUT IT WAS
PRETTY RAW DURING VIETNAM AND
THE END OF CIVIL RIGHTS.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE ONLY
THING MORE DIFFICULT SOCIALLY
THAN BEING A CONSERVATIVE IS
BEING A MODERATE THESE DAYS.
I CALL MYSELF A ROADKILL.
GET UP FROM THE LEFT, I GET UP
FROM THE RIGHT.
THE ONLY THING IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ROAD IS ROADKILL.
I’M ROADKILL.
>> Greg: BUT YOU ARE HANDSOME
ROADKILL.
EMILY, OUR COLLEGE IS A LOST
CAUSE FOR FREE THOUGHT?
>> Emily: MAY BECOME A BREAKER
I GREW UP WITHOUT SOCIAL MEDIA,
WITHOUT THE INTERNET.
>> Greg: ARE YOU AMISH?
>> Emily: I’M OLDER THAN I
LOOK.
I GREW UP IN THE BAY AREA, AND
EVERYBODY, THEY WERE STILL
PRACTICING HIPPIES FROM THE
APOSTASY 60s AND THEY TOTALLY FO
MY THEN GOLD TO BE A FIGHTER
PILOT.
I FEEL LIKE THIS MAKES ME SO SAD
TO SEE IN BERKELEY BECAUSE I
GREW UP IN SUCH A DIFFERENT
ENVIRONMENT EVEN THOUGH ALL
AROUND ME PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT SO
DIFFERENT FROM ME, I FELT SO
SUPPORTED.
THE FEDERALIST SOCIETY IN
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE MY WHOLE
ROLE IS BRINGING THE OTHER VIEW
TO DEBATE?
I NEVER GOT ANY CRAP FOR IT.
I’M NOT TRYING TO PAINT A ROSY
EXISTENCE.
MY BEST FRIEND AT HOME GOES TO A
REVOLUTIONARY MEETING EVERY
SUNDAY BUT FOR SOME REASON, DO
NOT KNOW IF IT’S THE
AMPLIFICATION FROM SOCIAL MEDIA
OR THE DIFFERENT TIMES, WHATEVER
IT IS, BUT IT DOESN’T FEEL LIKE
IT USED TO.
>> Greg: DANA, YOU ARE IN THE
WEATHER UNDERGROUND.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON’T KNOW THAT.
BUT IT USED TO BE YOU COULD ASK
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION.
I THINK IT’S THE IDENTITY
POLITICS, THE INTERSECTIONALITY
HAS CREATED A PRESSURE VERSUS
OPPRESSED.
>> Dana: ADD SOCIAL MEDIA TO
THE MIX AND IT’S VERY
COMBUSTIBLE.
I HAVE FRIENDS WHOSE KIDS ARE
GETTING READY TO GO TO COLLEGE
AND THEY ARE REALLY ARE AT A
LOSS, THEY DON’T KNOW WHAT TO DO
PRINT THEY ARE SUPER WORRIED
ABOUT IT, THEY WANT THEIR KIDS
TO BE ABLE TO GO TO A GOOD
PLACE.
IT’S INTERESTING THOUGH BECAUSE
THE INCREASE IN TUITION, YOU CAN
ALMOST TRACK THE INCREASE OF
THESE INCIDENTS.
A PLACE LIKE PURDUE UNIVERSITY
WHERE GOVERNOR RICH DANIELS IS
THE PRESIDENT, ANNOUNCED
YESTERDAY THEIR NINTH
CONSECUTIVE TUITION FREEZE.
THEY ARE USING FREE-MARKET
PRINCE BOWLS FIGURING OUT A WAY
AND THERE ARE UNIVERSES LIKE
THAT BUT THEY ARE THE EXCEPTION
EXCEPTION.
>> Greg: I’M GOING TO START
BUYING THEIR CHICKEN.
YOU HAVE DAUGHTERS WHO IN A
DECADE WILL BE COLLEGE-BOUND.
IS THIS GOING TO BOTHER YOU OR
YOU ARE GOING TO HOMESCHOOL?
>> Jesse: I GOT TO START
SAVING UP.
I’M GOING TO HOMESCHOOL, GREG.
I HAVE LIBERAL FRIENDS AND
CONSERVATIVE FRIENDS AND IT’S
GREAT BECAUSE WE ALL GET
TOGETHER, WE ALL MAKE FUN OF THE
LIBERALS.
THAT’S WHAT BEING IN COLLEGE IS
ABOUT.
YOU HAVE A FEW DRINKS AND YOU
TAKE SHOTS WITH PEOPLE WHO
DISAGREE WITH IN A TRAP AND YOUR
SKILLS.
IF YOU DID A CONSERVATIVE, THEY
CAN JUST PAY FOR DINNER.
>> Geraldo: IT’S INTERESTING.
HARD TIMES TO MAKE PEOPLE MORE
TOLERANT.